hey guys this is Pete peppers with candy
crush soda saga tips calm and this is a
candy crush soda saga level 127
walkthrough tutorial with tips this is a
tough level and one that excuse me that
I've been getting a lot of questions
about the last couple days so I just
thought I'd make this extra video with
some tips to help help you see how to go
about approaching it the main thing we
want to do in the first room is get out
of here with as many moves left as we
can in really no really no two ways
about that there's only one bear out
five so this room is really just just
hold you up you know so we just want to
take our time and find the best possible
matches or every time on every you know
jump and then puff the board cooperates
something like it did right here where I
can move the bear across the string I
got some specials there sometimes it'll
be all jammed up but this is it this is
the kind of level where you need a
pretty good board so you know it's
definitely not impossible so if you get
you know if you've got yourself really
stuck a few times just take it easy and
don't worry it'll eventually set up
right for you so here you'll one thing
you notice right away when you come into
this room is that there's less colors
and play than there were before which is
nice because we can make specials a lot
easier but you also want to pay
attention and make sure you don't go
crazy and sort of lose sight of what
you're trying to do we're trying to hit
these pieces right in front of the bear
move so you know that our our overall
goal is still the same I'm trying to get
out of here as fast as we can
a vertical stripe right here is really
good because it'll it'll move four
pieces out of our way right away but so
far at least I haven't been able to do
to set that up yet so there we go
so we'll do ahead and do that now the
fish actually helped us even more by
hitting the one that's right in front of
them which that is normal that'll happen
pretty much all the time all right so
this this room is where you usually run
out of moves and have to start over and
we do have a counter in candy to start
out but it really won't do us that much
help if we just fire it off to change
one of the colors what we need to do or
what I like to do I should say I guess
is like make a combo with it we have 20
moves and I would be glad to waste
several of them except meant that I
would get a combo so we need to examine
the board and as you can see I was able
to set up the stripes that I can match
with it now
and no reason to wait to set this off at
all it's going to turn all the yellow
and all the orders and the striped
candies it's gonna open things up pretty
good as you can see you get rid of a lot
of the the licorice from us and it
actually pops some bottles too
so now we just need to pop the rest of
them and get the Bears to move up across
all the licorice is gone so the official
bit of the Bears will go to the bottles
first and then they'll go to the pieces
in front of the Bears so we can go we
can go - pretty straightforward way
there's I don't have any direct matches
with wanna be right there with the
bottles I was going to say but look for
those first and then just look to move
things up and make fish
all right so now technically the Bears
can move across the string so I'm going
to go ahead and move these two out of
the way get them up there
and it probably seems like I'm taking a
little time here since I have 13 moves
and I'm pretty like that you get through
but you know I just want to show you
that taking time thinking is important
so here I can I can actually finish
because I can drop this orange and it's
gonna bring the red all the way up to
make that match and pop that out so
there it is
you know like I said it this level can
be really frustrating because the boards
won't always be that good I think this
was the fourth try or so that I didn't
write your I beated a long time ago and
I'm sure it took me a lot of tries the
first time too so just hang in there
take your time look for you know the
first room just looked at them quick
don't waste a lot of time getting
elaborate with things second room you
know concentrate on where it what you're
in therefore don't just start making
specials and try to get lucky to get the
bear to move up because it will likely
happen that way and then the last room
that's where you want to make sure that
you try to get a combo with the color in
candy because it's gonna make a lot of
difference so I hope this helped please
subscribe to our Channel and like the
video when you subscribe that supports
us and same with the like but also you
get the you'll know when we have new
videos coming out which is pretty much
all the time and you know we make these
ones with tips to really try to help
because not not anybody that I know of
does that and sometimes the video it's
great but you need a little bit more so
hope it helps and see you soon thanks